this is Bob Odenkirk and this is the
wired auto complete interview
open Kirk an actual lawyer you know what
a TV is right
when did Bob Odenkirk start acting about
the third season of Better Call Saul
most of my career I was a comedy writer
and then I I performed as a sketch actor
in many many sketches because that's
what I wrote but it was kind of a
fundamentally different thing to take on
the role of Saul Goodman Jimmy McGill in
Better Call Saul even different than
Breaking Bad I think there was a level
of acting of losing yourself in a role
of knowing a character in Better Call
Saul than anything I'd ever done I think
I got more of a handle on it
as it went third season was one I
remember showing up going you know let's
go to work I know what I know what I
need to do where's Bob odenkirk's star
it's on Vine north of Hollywood
Boulevard by about a block and a half
it's where we shot a Mr show scene you
could look up on YouTube it's pumpkin
any and then you'll see me right where
my star is but I didn't know I'd have a
star there one day when does Bob
Odenkirk appear in Breaking Bad the
final four episodes of the second season
and I was only in three of them because
I had to do How I Met Your Mother and
because I had to do How I Met Your
Mother they had to invent another
character to pull that plot along and
they invented Mike Ehrman trout so thank
God I was on How I Met Your Mother
because they could invent Mike and then
me and John Banks Could Do Better Call
Saul Bob Odenkirk Larry David when I was
at Saturday Night Live as a writer for
three and a half years I used to do the
Improv here in New York and Larry David
would go up too and he would just get
mad at the audience and he would be
getting laughs but he would get angry at
them and you'd be like Larry they liked
you he killed me he kills me he's the
funniest guy I love curb and I love
being on curb that was so much fun bob
Owen Kirk van down by the river I grew
up in Chicago and I went and saw Second
City when I was 14 and it really
inspired me to want to be in Showbiz and
sort of believe that you know adult
people work in Showbiz my friend Tom
Giannis was directing the main stage
show it's like a city he invited me to
join and be a part of that show so I
said yes I helped write the show in the
course of writing that show in the cast
was Chris Farley and I went home that
night and I wrote the motivational
speaker for Chris Farley exactly the way
you see it when he does it on SNL except
for the table breaking which was added
by Robert Smigel that's the story of
that
how did Bob Odenkirk get cast in
Breaking Bad a real good question and
when I hesitated to ask because I didn't
want to get kicked out of Breaking Bad I
didn't wanted them to rethink their
choice and Vince Gilligan uh and Peter
Gould who wrote the character of Saul
Goodman into the first script that he
was in in Breaking Bad we're both fans
of Mr Show and both thought I was the
guy to play the part
I don't know why Vince Gilligan is the
smartest guy in the room
but he pretends not to be he's got this
performance that he does you could call
it the aw shucks guy he secretly knows
that he's working really really hard and
he's also smart as so he listens to
people very very politely he's never
ever rude and then he does what he's
going to do and it's it's the right
thing every damn time how did Bob odkin
David Cross meet it's a famous story
Jeannie Garofalo was the kind of queen
pin of the alternative comedy scene back
in 92 93. I was sitting in my house in
the afternoon eating lunch Janine came
to my door the screen door was shut and
she's standing outside with her friend
David Cross and he has a basketball she
knocks on the door and I'm sitting right
there and I'm looking over here and she
goes hey Bob okay hey Janine uh this is
my friend David Cross from Boston hey
you guys uh he likes to play basketball
I know you do too do you want to play
and I go nah I'm eating and then they
left
it was one of the most embarrassing
things in David's life how is Bob
Odenkirk thank you for asking I did have
a heart incident also could be called a
heart attack feel free my Widowmaker
artery was totally blocked so you know
that's not good take my medicine I got
two stents in here working out hopefully
gonna get to do another action film
because I loved making that first one
I'm doing great thank you
okie dokie where is Bob Odenkirk from I
grew up in Naperville Illinois a really
nice town and nice people and all that I
was very bored with the town when I was
15 but I sure enjoyed being a kid there
and I don't mind going back I like it
there I go visit my sisters who still
live there Ken Bob Odenkirk still win an
Emmy yeah but I think every five
nominations equals a win can Bob
Odenkirk sing no no no no I cannot but I
will I'm a terrible singer and I love to
make people listen to me sing does
Robert and Kirk play guitar not well I
can play though I can hack around on it
Bob Odenkirk lucky Hank lucky Hank is a
unique show in that it's kind of 50 50
comedy and drama that's not easy to do
because if you get too silly you stop
believing in the stakes of the dramatic
part so you need to stay connected with
the people you need to believe in those
hungers and desires and problems and yet
there are also some pretty purely funny
scenes there are no zombies there are no
guns there are no drugs there's no drug
cartel there's no Mafia there's people
in Academia they're professors and
students at a small College that's
having financial problems and they try
to make a go of it which is to say it's
like life
what did Bob Odenkirk write on SNL not
much I was not a very effective writer
on Saturday Night Live I struggled
mightily I really wanted to help out at
the show but I hadn't focused enough on
SNL when I got there to ask what does
this show do what does it need to do
what does it want to do I just wanted to
write something that made me laugh I was
very lucky I was sort of helping out
Robert Smigel who was maybe the best
writer they've ever had at Saturday
Night Live but I only helped I only
wrote a couple jokes in there maybe gave
it a turn I actually got better towards
the end I was able to help Chris Rock
and Farley and Sandler to put some
scenes up and of course I wrote the
motivational speaker for Chris Farley so
that's the best thing I did for SNL but
I wrote that in Chicago for Second City
not for Sno what has Bob Odenkirk
directed I've directed a couple feature
films and many episodes of TV that
you've never seen I mean the movies
didn't turn out great but in some ways
they were successful to me let's go to
prison I really want wanted it to feel
like a 70s black exploitation film and
we had a lot of fun with the camera like
they did in those movies and we wanted
it to have a gritty feel because the
material the subject matter is kind of
rough stuff but it just didn't win
people over brother Solomon admittedly I
didn't know what I was doing I knew how
to direct but I just didn't know how to
make this movie work Will Forte wrote
that script and it's full of heart and
it's really sweet and fun and everybody
of course showed up to work and then I
let him down I wish I could reshoot that
and if I could I would reshoot it as an
indie film with no built sets and those
characters interacting with real people
as much as possible be a better idea
than what I did what episode of The
Office is Bob odenkarkan was like season
six or seven or something the joke was
they said Jenna's character uh it goes
to interview for a job somewhere else it
turns out her boss would just be a
duplicate of Michael Scott so I was kind
of riffing on Steve Carell's excellent
performance when I did that what episode
of Seinfeld does Bob odenker again the
abstinence one where nobody's having sex
and it's making them smarter because
they're not having sex and I play a
Doctor Who's going to take the mcats and
he does well because he because Elaine
won't have sex with him what did Bob
Odenkirk do in The Incredibles I played
the network executive who wants to give
them a show and sculpt them in certain
ways I seem to be the bad guy spoiler
alert I'm not the character is a genuine
character who loves the the family of
The Incredibles
did Bob Odenkirk audition for Michael
Scott I did I couldn't wait to audition
I did my best I think I did a great job
supposedly it was between me and Corral
and he got it and he did so great and
he's the best the best at Michael Scott
did Bob wooden Kirk write better call so
I didn't I didn't write any of it
occasionally we'd get a scene that was
kind of pure funny and then I would feel
more free to suggest to Peter Gould you
know how about I say this or that but
that show was not one where you goofed
around or improvised did Bob and Kirk
write for The Simpsons I didn't my
brother Bill did for many many years he
also has a doctorate in chemistry from
the University of Chicago did Bob
Odenkirk play football I played football
on my junior high team I was really a
little guy and they put me in safety I
did okay but everyone was so much bigger
than me
Bob Odenkirk Robin Williams Robin
Williams was extremely kind to me and
David Cross when we did comic relief 8.
our show Mr Show with Bob and David was
not a massive hit it was the definition
of a cult hit we were invited to do
comic relief 8 and uh nobody knew who we
were the other two hosts kind of rolled
their eyes at us and Robin came up to us
and said you guys are great and he had
seen Mr show he loved comedy it meant a
lot to me you know and then I got to be
in a movie with them I think it was his
last film Boulevard I very much enjoyed
uh performing with him that was hard how
that ended Bob Odenkirk Little Women an
unbelievable gift I have two kids of my
own and the book is one of the greatest
books of all time that cast is a
ridiculously talented wonderful cast
credit Gerwig is an amazing director we
had so much fun I had so much fun just
being around the energy of that young
cast and I absolutely love and and will
always be thankful I got to play father
March Bob Odenkirk Larry Sanders I got
to play Stevie Grant on the Larry
Sanders show it was really my first
acting gig I know we talked about my
first acting that probably is really it
Larry Sanders is a great show if you've
never seen it it's a comedy but played
very grounded it was a wonderful thing
to be a part of just all good actors and
great to be on that set Bob Odenkirk
book review Thanks for asking I should
do a book review show because I read a
lot and lately my favorite books one's
called guilty of everything by John
Auber Armstrong he was in a rock band
The modernettes and he's a great writer
and I'm reading another of his books
right now called wages and it's
hilarious I also published a memoir last
year comedy comedy comedy drama that
tells you a lot of the stories I just
told you or in more depth also I have a
book coming out a book that I I wrote
with my kids when they were little and
it's a book of poems and it's called
zylit
z-i-l-o-t zealit
well there you go that's all there is to
know about me thank you for asking
[Music]